yeah the SPCA is normally for owner
surrender it's not the Strays that are
picked up by animal control but for the
last week they've had to take in a lot
more animals on top of the ones that
they already care for
[Music]
dogs desperate for a home
and staff anxious for updates from the
animal foundation I know that they have
their hands full
I think that we just feel it's very sad
for all of us we're with the Nevada SPCA
says their phones have been ringing off
the hook from Animal Control Officers
literally Clark County Animal Control
had dogs on their trucks with no place
to put them the problem is their
facility isn't equipped for large
volumes of dogs but they did take a few
from Animal Control and the foundation
of course we wanted to do what we can to
help the community one dog is currently
in medical isolation to make sure it
isn't sick it's a crisis meanwhile
private search and rescue groups like
the doggy task force have to think twice
before responding to a dog sighting I
carry a baby gate this is my microchip
scanner the rescues they're they're
scrambling they're pulling their hair
out it's always been a case about Foster
space now it's worse it's because they
would bring in a stray or a lost and
found to the animal foundation and now
they have no place to go unless a team
member can keep the dog overnight which
means they can't respond to every call
people of my network just Reach Out I
mean they know how nervous I am about
this issue
they know how
and how much uh this is breaking my
heart
[Music]
the animal foundation says they're only
taking in sick or vicious dogs and the
city of Las Vegas animal control says
they're responding based on a Case by
case Victoria Saha eight news now